foreign
[Applause]
I hope all of you are recuperating I
know I am
covered myself in barbecue sauce
then I turned out the lights
we'll get to that later Larry all right
recently ESPN Samantha Ponder expressed
support for athletes speaking out
against biological men who keep trying
to compete with women in sports you know
the guys who keep putting the meat in
swim meet
that's disgusting
Ponder tweeted I barely said anything
publicly about this issue and I've had
so many people message me stop me in the
street to say thank you and tell me
stories about girls who are afraid to
speak up for fear of lost employment or
being called hateful but it's not
hateful to demand fairness in sports for
girls and she's right that's logical
that's fair it's based on irrefutable
scientific fact so what happens next
well liberals in the media are Furious
because well they're stupid
and what do they do to a woman speaking
out against the bullying of women they
bully her of course riding in on her
broomstick is Nancy armor a ghastly
Sports columnist for USA Today the
official doormat for Americans staying
at low priced hotels
if the La Quinta Inn goes out of
business so does she
the god-awful armor writes quote don't
be fooled by the people who Screech
about fairness to cloak their bigotry
towards transgender girls and women this
is and always was about hate fear and
ignorance well if you're talking about
her columns you couldn't be more right
they suck this broad accuses Ponder of
screeching but she's not the one
leveling unprovable accusations it seems
to me old Nance is projecting like a
drive-in theater
how about this gem quote I'm at a loss
as to how a transgender woman going to a
gynecologist takes anything away from
anyone or how it's any of Ponder's
business yeah well the rest of us are
wondering why a transgender woman needs
to go to a gynecologist
unless he's suffering from jock itch
I've been there but it's like a USA
Today writer going to see a brain
surgeon
what's to operate on Armor then accuses
Ponder of piling on a group that is
already amongst the most vulnerable in
our society
so who's she talking about man she's
talking about men see here's the thought
process all men are evil right up to the
moment they decide they're actually
women then suddenly suddenly their
rights override everybody else's rights
especially women who have been women the
whole damn time
Finance is a female sports writer not a
young superlative athlete so that might
be the problem here Envy failure spite
she's not a winner like they are and she
hates them for it but I'll bet armor
still considers herself a feminist and
I'm not saying that because she looks
like a young Pete Rose
[Applause]
thank you what the hell did Pete Rose do
to anybody I know but most feminists
don't try to ruin the careers and lives
of other young women and calling someone
a bigot minus any evidence is an attempt
to do just that and so armor just
created a new athletic event throwing
women under the bus hopefully a man is
driving the bus and will skillfully
avoid hitting them
just making sure you're awake
accusations of bigotry are a dime a
dozen especially from hacks but it's not
just name calling it's actually a
serious slander for the accusation
carries social stigmas that will follow
you online forever and that's the point
isn't it that the threat of the smear
will scare you into silence which is
what Omar hopes to do to high-level
female athletes suddenly pro-women
athletes are now redefined as anti-trans
and what happens when you label that
well just ask a JK Rowling whose life
was turned upside down by unhinged rabid
activists of course it's a sign of the
weakness in their argument rather than
debate they denunciate they smear and
when you assert the obvious that men and
women are indeed different in placing
bio men among women will be unfair in
sports
they will call you a bigot because well
at least she is a profoundly political
anti-science hack
but screw her and the smears she wrote
in on basic human biology isn't going to
change no matter how many cruddy columns
Nancy craps out terrible writing might
be in her DNA but a y chromosome isn't
[Applause]
nice yes
he hides his money in his socks and
fastens them with locks oh Steph Kudlow
on Fox Business Larry Kudlow
his act is a lap a minute which actually
isn't a lie
actor comedian and writer Jamie listow
she needs a running start to use a
stapler Fox News contributor Kat too
and finally the Grand Canyon is his
cereal bowl
there you go
So Jamie I was just thinking you know uh
it's always a pleasure to see you here
if you were a trans athlete do you think
it would have prevented your divorce
that is the meanest worst question
I'm trying to break the ice break the
ice you shattered the ceiling
I don't think anything uh would have
prevented it sorry to get rid of the
following questions you have for the
next 10 episodes
um
that really made um this oh this story
by the way yes by the way that was
really cool I didn't even have to
respond Tyler's had my back it felt good
yeah man I felt safe I could be um you
this this story like you know me like I
can be liberal sometimes when I'm
pouring drinks or describing my penis
over the phone
um
whoa and these guys
those guys don't call him after eight
part of this was they didn't even so
glad to be here
I should have warmed up into that one um
it's It's upsetting to watch for me I
feel bad for the kids the worst thing
I've ever seen is when this happens in
MMA there's nothing worse yeah I watched
a man like a it looked like a big actual
man and it looked like he was fighting
like like a it was it looked like abuse
right honestly like I was disgusted like
I pulled my pants up I turned it off and
um
one more I go I can't even finish um
I don't know just no no
I was thinking about it and then I was
like that one felt pretty good no I just
I just think calling her a bigot is at
first I was like I think they misspelled
the biologist
that's good that was a good clean joke
thank you people are going to write in
and say why doesn't Jamie do more jokes
like that instead of talking about his
genitalia Larry Kudlow
what does this say about USA Today USA
Today is like a kind of a husk of a
paper and they need hot takes for click
bait is that kind of the business model
here because you are the businessman
I'm really glad to be here tonight yeah
I want to thank you for inviting me
particularly with this topic yes
I I don't have much to say in defense of
USA Today
I do think however biological males
should not play in female sports I think
that's the cool thing
and
I've thought long and hard about this
and so beyond that early point that I
just made I just wanted to know if you
realized that the Kevin McCarthy deal on
the debt ceiling is really terrific he
completely spun Biden around cutting two
trillion dollars it's a record amount no
tax increases caps on future spending
and it's really going to help economic
growth and reduce inflation I know that
was implied in your question so I just
thought I'd fill it in
don't you hate this the the farce of the
debt ceiling where everybody in cable TV
pretends it's the end of the world you
could just turn it off and turn it on in
a week and everything's the same I I
swore on the five we would never do the
debt ceiling thing because it's so
fake and also what the hell is a debt
ceiling
should it be more money like what is the
like it is such a farce we're over that
Larry take your debt silly crap get it
out of here
it's sort of a
transgenderism of Economics it really it
really is well there you go there we go
you brought it together
hilarious
[Applause]
I just spirited the show Kat what do you
make of this uh you know you're a writer
she often takes political angles but I
just feel that
what does she know about sports really
yeah she probably didn't want to spend
that much time on it I mean it was a
holiday weekend yeah that's right this
came out on Memorial Day exactly which
is how you get crap like this
because she knows
she doesn't either do the editors yeah
because everybody wants the time off
everybody's off and I I think that's how
you get an article that is just lacking
any sort of attempt at evidence to make
the points uh because nowhere in the
article did she claim there's no
evidence that somebody goes through you
know male puberty would have advantages
over a woman in sports because there is
evidence that suggests that and when you
say I just throw the word bigotry at
anybody who thinks that that's a
possibility then you're completely
deluding the whole entire thing but
again it's probably hard to find people
to ride over the holiday weekend yes
that's a good point last word to you
Tyrus
I I think it's such a we're talking
about her so mission accomplished and
what we're seeing now today is you don't
need to have an argument because you
really shouldn't be debating these
individuals because it's not an exchange
of ideas the only person who has an idea
is the one who came in the normal person
is trying to understand and their idea
changes to why did I just waste my time
right she wrote that article and now
she's become a champion for them so
chances are she's going to get more
opportunities because that makes no
sense that used to be we used to make
fun of like brothers who would have
excuses for failing it was always a
teacher's racist my girlfriend don't
because she's racist yeah you know it
was yeah that's right it took a while
and then she put a tactile attached all
the dots and realized he was black and
left me in the second like really it
wasn't because you're a jerk who was
cheating it was because your girlfriend
was slow racist so what we're seeing is
that
it's a thing slow racism it's like slow
slow it takes you a long time to realize
that there's no definition of a woman
I'm still stuck with the actual
definition that what a woman is but
isn't it the most toxic
masculine male thing to do to hop out of
a division you can't compete in and show
up and compete against somebody smaller
than you isn't that like the worst guy
we've seen them all in the playground
and stuff like the 13 year old kid who
jumps in with the seven-year-olds to
play soccer no one's cheering for him no
I don't think it's cheer for me once oh
good job good they're like wow look at
this guy what does he play with someone
with his own size or his own age well
same question to the transgender dudes
who are attacking women and the MMA
thing was awful yeah that was absolutely
awful and we need to be able to say no I
it's become a new thing like what is
you're going to get asked two questions
when you run for office now or you apply
for a job do you know what a woman is
and should men play be able to be women
in women's sports yeah and if you say no
and no then you can only work here yeah
you can answer that in one question and
answer you and go I know what a woman is
that's not a woman yeah
thank you for your time thank you for
your time with running like you don't
want to reach back and the batons
attached
and I think well
Larry how's that debt ceiling looking
pretty good uh I tried you did I really
tried he's not big fan of ceilings hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else